come out for the first movie the
question is what happens when the leader
of your ball Center what happens when
that's gone how does Superman's death
impacts his world
the beginning of the reign of the
supermen I think is straight to kind of
introduction of these replacements these
four supermen woods they each represent
you really saw Lois take control of the
story what if one of them really is
Clark reborn
are any of them the real Superman or a
trace of the real Superman
Superman represents hope and at the end
of death of Superman that hope is lost
the question of where we go from there
is what we're trying to explore with
this story we learn from Superman
doomsday deliver the full novel we're
gonna cover the complete story as a
two-parter we were able to take the book
and amplify it kick up the stakes a
little bit so the threat it's more
threatening than ever the four supermen
they each have their own agenda some
good some bad
Superboy is ace it's Superman if he had
been raised by the Kardashians John
Henry irons represents the humanity and
heart that is that Superman brings to
the show the Eradicator represents the
quarter of Superman that is the last Son
of Krypton cyborg Superman is really the
power of Superman
it's just a little devoid of of emotion
death of Superman is about how we
destroy our heroes and reign of the
Superman is about how we make them
they both have a lot to say about about
us
when Superman is gone is the hope gone I
think that we find it we may not be able
to bring the beat down but we sure as
hell can make some noise am i right
hey everybody its charlie they're
finally doing reign of the supermen how
many people remember collecting those
comics this was actually the very first
comic book arc that I would peddle
around town two gas stations looking for
the next title in the series because it
would cross over all the Superman titles
and they would have like that little
triangle number on it so you knew which
order to collect them in this is all
following the events of Death of
Superman so you can kind of see how
they're just building on the big
Superman Justice League arcs in the
comics so after this maybe we'll do
Emerald Twilight Emerald dawn the war of
light Sinestro Corps war all the big
arcs that the death in return of
Superman built up towards in DC Comics
history if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the DC videos there's gonna be a lot of
DC animation in the next year between
this Young Justice Teen Titan season 6
I'll link that trailer at the end of
this to because that was a big surprise
this weekend but the big thing here is
them refreshing that classic reign of
the Superman comic arc with modern
designs so the writing there Conner Kent
Superboy to be more modern-day punk
instead of 90s punk rock if you look at
some of the original dialogue and some
of the sayings that he had it actually
seems kind of silly now you're like this
is how people actually talked in the 90s
is this supposed to be cool I can't tell
because it just seems really silly they
use the Kardashians reference in this
but really Conner Kent within this reign
of the Superman arc obviously most of
you know some version of the character
but during this storyline he just meant
to represent the celebrity aspect of
Superman
cranked up to 11 like look at me I'm so
awesome I'm the most powerful person on
the planet isn't it so awesome to be a
celebrity like that's why they mentioned
Kardashians because the Kardashians are
famous for being celebrities I don't
think they've revealed that he was the
STAR Labs clone till later in the arc
and he originally they were intending
just a clone Superman but Lex Luthor
found out about it and mixed his DNA in
there to lathe special controls so that
he would be able to take over Superboy's
mind when he became older so that all
went down in a completely separate comic
book arc for the most part that was just
a way to sort of give him a really crazy
origin story that they could mine for
drama later but also deep our him a
little bit because all these Superman
have
aspects of Superman's powers or his
personality but you have to imagine that
was like DC dividing all of his powers
into four quarters so like cyborgs
Superman in the Eradicator feel like
they're almost as powerful as Superman
but there are a lot of limitations to
that so John Henry irons is obviously
just meant to represent the everyman
aspect of Superman the blue-collar guys
just trying to make his world a better
place with every action he takes whether
it's saving people on the street or
being a symbol of justice he constructs
a suit that gives him Superman like
abilities but he's never quite as
powerful as some of the more genetically
based supermen the backstory of the
Eradicator is actually pretty
complicated they wreck haunted a couple
times but it's basically a Kryptonian
program meant to preserve its culture
and protect Kryptonians at every cost so
when Superman is almost killed by
doomsday everyone thinks he's dead
because of the biological readings but
he's just on the edge of death so they
put him in a tomb the Eradicator program
is activated it uses DNA taken from
Superman's birthing chamber to create a
body for itself so that also gives it
the memories of Superman's so that's why
it thinks that it's Superman at first
because it's not really a Superman it
can absorb sunlight so it has to use
Superman so it steals his body takes it
back to the fortress of solitude sticks
it in a healing matrix where Superman
just chills out for the entire arc in
the Eradicator in order to power himself
up like Superman has to vampire yellow
sunlight through the real Superman's
body so it sort of uses him as a tether
it has a side effect of that process
Superman's real body the real Superman
gets energized it heals his cells and he
comes back to life it just takes a long
time for that to happen but that's why
the Eradicator wears that yellow band
across his eyes because he's sensitive
to sunlight and he can't give off heat
vision but he can't give off energy
blast from his hands and because he's
the Eradicator he has some of Superman's
memories but none of his compassion so
at first glance he's just meant to feel
like the stabby hardcore version of
Superman but he's really just a
Kryptonian program walking around in a
Superman looking body
cyborg Superman's backstory is way more
complicated so most of you probably know
he's Hank Henshaw even if you haven't
read the comics you've only seen the
Supergirl version of the character
it's basically
hank henshaw stealing Clark Kent's DNA
making himself look like Superman albeit
with you know half cyborg features the
way he explains it when he shows up to
because he's trying to pretend to be
Superman isn't that he says that he was
damaged in the fight with doomsday and
that's why he has the cybernetic parts
but really it's the other way around he
was pure cyborg
he grew himself Clark Kent's skin to
wear on top of himself same deal with
his powers as with the Eradicator 's
because he's a derivative of Superman
but has some of his DNA he has some of
Superman's original powers but he's not
quite as powerful the whole thing with
his character though is that he's
playing the long con to get people to
trust him the way they trusted Superman
so that he can destroy the world that
winds up culminating in him destroying
Coast City which drives Hal Jordan
insane leaving him to succumb to the
parallax entity DC used that to reboot
their Green Lantern comics so Hal Jordan
parallax kills pretty much the entire
Green Lantern Corps they reboot it when
Geoff Johns took over the title did
Emerald dawn led the Sinestro Corps war
the war of light blackest night
brightest day so you can kind of see how
DC animation is moving through these big
comic book arcs so what they might do
after the reign of the Superman is
return of Superman then maybe they'll
move into some of the bigger Green
Lantern comic book arcs and do the war
of light Sinestro Corps war let me know
in the comments what you think of the
reign of the Superman's storyline and if
you actually did try to collect it when
it was in comic book stores what'll
happen is is there's all kinds of
infinity war blu-ray bonus features that
are posting in the next couple of days
but leave all your DC requests in the
comments below click here to watch that
Teen Titans Season 6 trailer again and
click here to rewatch The Young Justice
Season 3 trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]